us
uh giving a talk about game dynamics and
uh first of all
it's a great pleasure to see you up
close
and uh yeah the same here for everybody
the flow is
amazing to yours here
so let's see uh
uh
so there is the nash equilibrium
it really started modern game theory
and
i i'm sure you know that it started
modern economics
so
so 1950 was the watershed moment
uh
because uh
uh
uh not only because uh
this this
tremendously important concept was
defined
but also because
it inspired other people
to do even greater things okay like like
prove walruses conjecture
and uh
uh
it is uh it has become the archetypical
solution concept in game theory by
typically i mean
uh
that
everything else disjudged and compared
with it okay
so um
uh
what camino
we have been singing its phrases for you
for decades all right let me know it is
elegant it's compelling it's universal
that
what it is
it is uh in some sense a powerful
conceptual tool
in the following way
that it it's a license
to all economists
when they contemplate a design or a
situation
uh to sit back and say okay let's see
what happens at equilibrium
okay so so it's it's an incredible tool
it's it's character credibility
sculptor's tool okay
uh
and and
so meyerson for example
said in 1999
that the nash equilibrium lies at the
foundations of more than economic
thought i mean i believe the bullet
number two is what he thought what he
was thinking when he thought he said
this
uh
i mean the last quarter century computer
scientists have been uh uh
mingling with the economists to study
game theory economics and certainly the
nash equilibrium and this has been
always been even before before the
agt started a very uh
tentative relationship okay so you know
because uh uh
you know for some reason i mean i i'm
studying by this statement okay it does
not mix well with computation okay nas
did not have computation in mind when
when he came up with it uh
for example uh it is intractable
okay uh and and uh even for two-player
games
and uh
you know to to explicate this
let me take you uh 70-something years
earlier uh you know so this is i don't
know if you know this
exchange uh
nash
told for neumann what here done and for
neumann
the the best words that he could find to
to
encourage a young man who like
accomplished something so you know
what's this okay
so uh
okay so you know
and in some sense i mean though
the the the roots of the complexity like
that okay
you know the man was right when i said
when they say the man i mean the man
okay you know
so uh
that's because because uh uh the the the
source of nice equilibrium computational
trouble if it is a fixed point in a
generic way okay it's just a fixed point
right
uh and uh
it has no extra simplifying structure
okay it took a lot of work to prove it
but you know that's not it has no yet
therefore
generic fixed point
is exactly what you mean
by ppid complete these days
okay
good
so
but is it
really bad news i mean why should
economists care about this
because i mean we all have
uh we all know people who have made a
decent and sometimes lucrative life by
by solving epic complete problems so
interactable problems
all right
so amino does interact ability mean
anything i mean in practice some would
say not much okay
but in theory
okay
the point is that mass equilibrium was
not meant as a as a practical concept
that's equilibrium was meant as a
theoretical tool
okay
and interactability is almost as amount
as saying
as if nasa's theorem was saying that for
almost all pro
games there is enough equilibrium um i'm
here to
uh conjecture that if this was the proof
this was the theorem
of nash uh it wouldn't have been as as
as
famous
okay would not have launched modern
economic thought
okay
any questions
for example
roger meyerson
nobody would take seriously a solution
concept that is
it is empty for some games
okay and we know that there are these
games that that uh
of course this and our friends have
constructed
which
i mean they are completely
out of this universe but still i mean
they don't have essentials they don't
have much equilibrium not in this
universe okay
good
okay so that's uh one one theoretical
problem one computational problem that's
equilibrium there is more uh
the second one is that it's not unique
okay so it is it is uh not algorithm an
algorithmic concept okay it's sort of
it's it's not a prescription it tells
you uh if they ever acquires there's
going to be do this with this thing okay
so and and
some very clever people okay so you know
two nobel laureates uh
tried to fix this okay worked extremely
hard
wrote a hard to read book
uh which css is a complete flop okay so
you know so it's you know this is a
quagmire okay so you know if you try to
if you try if the equilibrium selection
problem sort of you know is amino has
has some
some amazing insights or you know
uh like like like focal point and so on
you know but what i'm saying it's it's
it's it is a quagmire it is it is a lost
okay
uh
so
uh when you tell economists uh
uh
i i i share your refugees like for for
last equilibrium but consider one two
and three okay
so they say uh
the players eventually will get there
okay
however here is the fact
that all known learning dynamics failed
to convex smash equilibrium okay
this includes dozens of learning
dynamics that if you read between the
lines of the papers they were explicitly
constructed to lead nash equilibrium
okay so there is a long list of of of
attempts to create dynamics that lived
on national equilibrium and they didn't
know god anywhere
often they sometimes do only reside they
converge other conditions like the game
be zero sum or
one player has two strategies
okay or both
so
uh
so i mean
in some sense that's another uh
minus four the mass equilibrium okay so
you know that it doesn't even
seem to have dynamics
that point to it
okay it does not mix well with dynamics
and because i mean one of the perhaps
the basic you know one of the most uh
sort of powerful uh
reasons for this is is what what uh
georgia's and panagiotis
proved
that the other year that
this
that
dynamics tend to cycle okay so
you know even in zero sum games okay
and and uh
even if sort of you know you try hard
for them not to
uh
good
uh i think i've been talking about
dynamics enough that i should explain
what i mean by this okay uh a dynamics
is something like this okay so in other
words a a uh
a motion of a point in uh a well this
prescribed motion of a point in in high
dimensional space okay what is it it is
my flow in domain x is a continuous map
from
the reals
which is time
and x to x okay so
this
must satisfy this okay so you know
that's that
time adds up okay so that's a semi flow
why do i exist on semi flow there is no
reason
mathematicians
usually think about flaws which means
that things happen started
at minus infinity and and
when i say this my uh audience starts
sorry you know starts looking at the
ceiling okay you know but you know but
flow is something we understand okay now
is zero and what will happen in the
future okay
uh okay so equivalently i mean you can
you can do it another way is a direction
and speed of motion at each point okay a
vector at each point
because if you have this uh it's not
exactly equivalent this this leads to
differential flows differentiable flows
but but
if you have if you have
if you have the direction of the speed
of motion you can integrate and find the
flow the
semi-flow okay
uh
so this is this is what equilibrium is i
have spent the previous slides telling
you that people have been trying to find
such things that converge the nasa
equilibrium
therefore i presume that this question
that i'm stating here
this is an important problem
find a way to assign to each game g
a dynamical system continues all the
script because because i forgot to
mention to emphasize this uh
there is also
discrete time version okay where you
where you have perhaps these are more
familiar to us uh but x of t plus one is
phi of x of t okay so you know this is
the the thing that gives the chaos even
in two dimensions in one dimension so
you know and and so on so we have we
know these things a lot and the point is
the following
that
but
what's the reason why i forgot to
mention it because as i have
incidentally all these these are things
that i learned from georgia's okay you
know so so you know including this okay
you know so that that there are there
are sort of uh profound and and uh not
easy to explain reasons
why
there is no difference between discrete
and you know except for details okay you
know there is no difference between
discrete and
equilibria so you know that that
whatever you can prove for one you work
a little more improved for that
okay i mean
with with huge exceptions but but i mean
this is this this seems to be a good
pattern okay
and we'll see it actually at work here
okay
so this question has to be important
uh
how can you find a way
so that for each game
you can assign
a function fee
with respect to the utility functions of
the players um so contracting mapping
yeah so it wouldn't work
but but that might be hard yeah no no it
would work
i mean
you know to contract to a particular
so so you know there is no simple
solution sorry
but i know uh
so
find a way to assign each game a
dynamical system
uh continue so discrete time
i will be very impressed with this free
time or continuous such that the
dynamics always converges to the nas
equilibrium okay so let's agree that
this is an interesting problem and i'm
going to continue all right
okay
here's the possibility theorem uh
there is no such dialogue
okay it's it's for recent work with
jason milos who is first year
phds here in columbia
georgia's and the kelly spanlov who is
algebraic topologist from uh oxford
not now not google i believe yeah yeah
so to clarify the quantifier is you're
even allowing to change the dynamics
per game right yeah i mean every game
for every game i want to have
let's say i don't even require a
polynomial time algorithm i want to have
sort of some kind of
oh my god this is rap
for which yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's exactly what
the video says yeah thanks
thanks for giving away my budget
okay so so uh for proof of impossibility
theorem it's it uses something called
anthropology algebraic topology index
theory uh in
yeah in particular the conley index okay
so this name you'll hear again uh
algebraic topology and dynamical system
so it's it's sort of you know it it uses
knowledge from this field and
what is an attractor okay attractor you
have heard the you know it's an
important uh
concept it is something that attracts
okay it is it is a set
so that uh everything that starts there
stays there but moreover something that
is not exactly there enter ends up there
okay so it attracts
uh
and um
okay so that's that's what that's what
the last line says
and and uh
okay
find so basically what the theorem says
find the dynamics such that the nas
equilibria is an attractor of it okay
uh that's not sufficient how about
cycles and spurious fixed points right
let me know you know what i'm saying you
know so okay so so that that's uh uh so
that's not good okay
so for energy find the dynamics fee so
i'm restating the problem okay such that
the nasa economy of g
is an attractor of fee that has an empty
dual repair in other words empty dual
repeller is the staff that don't go to
this attractor
okay so you want this to be empty
everything you've got with this
attractor no cycles no spurious exploits
okay so that's this this is this is the
this is the the what we're after and
we're going to show that this does not
exist
[Music]
and
like are you talking about is there a
competition here
i can find all
the issue is that there might be
multiple mesh equilibrium
[Music]
okay
so i think i see the slide
this creates subtle restrictions on the
nasa columbia
okay that are not obvious okay the whole
space of mixed strategy x must be
eventually converted to that equilibria
so basically what we want is if it has
not do any better we want everything to
eventually come to the nash equilibria
okay
and and
as a result
the nas equilibria must look a little
like x okay here is why
because sort of you know imagine that i
have a set okay
and i i apply a a
semi flow to it okay it becomes this set
this set is a has to be a little like
this okay
you know in other words in some in some
in some deep structural manner which i'm
going to explain in other words in the
in the deep nature of their cycles that
exist in this space cannot change yeah
there's a
there's a gap i'm still missing
something which is the game has to
generate the dynamics in some fashion
but there's some flexibility in how
dynamics is during the game you can't
just i mean i can always just say
go to the nash equilibrium for this game
and just everything should converge
there there has to be some constraint
okay let's try that
okay
this means that uh that you go through
another equilibrium
and uh you we ignore it okay so it's not
a fix it's not an exploit it's not it's
not part of the practice
okay forget my example
what's that what's the rule for
that all the attractor has to be precise
okay so i i suspect that the slide later
people say ah
okay so so wait
your difference
okay in particular they have to they
must have the same condo index what is
the container
the conda index
is
so
x and the magical number of g must have
the same conditions for every
game g okay so i'm slowly uh
revealing to you the constraints that
this this thing puts right
uh conlay index captures the structure
of the cycles in a set
it is an invariant the dynamical system
does not change
okay
so it is i mean let's let's not define
exactly what it is but but that's its
basic property
so let's uh start looking for some weird
games okay and there is a one which
we call m uh to honor mertens mertens
and it's an interesting example
that they came up in the study of
strategically stable nash equilibria and
it is it is uh uh
this this game it's a it's a it's a
subtle uh variant of rock paper scissors
uh three by three
uh it was also studied by benaim for for
half of power and serene
ten years ago in their attempt to prove
exactly the same theorem
okay
so don't i mean i don't think you'll
figure it out i'll tell you the secret
source that it has
okay the secret sauce is
uh
uh
f
m is highly degenerate
and the nas equilibria are a hexagon on
the boundary of the simplex product okay
imagine a simple export you can imagine
these four dimensions okay but imagine
imagine imagine a polytope
and a hexagon
on its on it's on its facets okay
that's the nas equilibria that's the set
of nash equilibria
of this game
okay
now that explain this
isn't it intuitively obvious that you
cannot have a
a uh
a
flow a
uh
you know imagine the following okay i
give you the earth and i let you i tell
you every every molecule in the earth
must go to the equator sorry to the
equator yes exactly okay
how do you do that
i mean i know that many of you think you
can do that
but consider the center of the earth
it will stay there
it will be a spurious
fixed point
okay so this is the idea and it takes
two pages of math i don't understand to
to prove it okay
everybody got this
yeah
the whole the whole hexagon okay so you
know in other words the points the edges
everything okay
that these are the nice equilibria
no no sorry sorry sorry i meant the
periph the perimeter of a hexagon i'm
sorry i meant the perimeter of a hexagon
sorry
okay
okay
uh
remember i go to find the game who's
nasty caribbera are not all
at all like x okay and indeed a hexagon
does not look at all like refer for the
simplex product
but in what precise mathematical sense
in the sense captured by the common
index okay the measure the nature of it
recycles
since the comp the the conladex as i i'm
asking you to believe is invariant in
other words if you apply a
dynamical system transformation to it
stays the same so that the body stays
the same we're done
okay there is no dynamics for this game
okay
okay it also holds for for
for you know there is also a proof well
you know it takes a little a little
trouble but but in some sense uh
ceremonial trouble so you know you do
the same things that you have done
elsewhere so you know to to to transfer
it to transfer the pools to discrete
time
but the function the mapping itself
uh so okay
so that's uh
uh
can be extended with work to discrete
time
christmas
so this is this is excluding the
possibility of finding dynamics that
converge that have that all nash
equilibria are fixed points right or
they're all negative
but if we only wanted one we wouldn't
have a problem right uh
yes
so i'm coming to that like so actually
actually actually actually so you know
the next you know the next uh
result okay so here is another how about
non-degenerate okay so this is the
gender we know that almost all games
how about approximation okay so here is
the theorem there is no dynamics that
converges to a 10 percent approximate
equilibrium for almost all
normalized games okay
not for almost all sorts of strategies
what do i want to say
for uh not for almost all that's wrong
for uh uh for a
for a for a full dimensional ball
okay
so
so please forget for almost all okay uh
it's it's around you know you understand
what i'm saying so what i'm saying is
that there you know this is sort of you
know almost this is sort of measure zero
stuff okay
but you can find a full dimensional ball
okay
or gains
for which and largely sort of you know
it's not infinite there's my large one
you know relatively large one so that
uh you cannot have
a temp you know all tempers you know you
cannot have a dynamics for these games
that converge
to ten percent approximate nash
equilibrium
okay if you remember ten percent is what
is what this is sort of you know what we
can do in polynomial time about okay
so so just to be clear uh
games with isolated equilibrium
does
this isolated
[Music]
is how it looks
you know basically it's a
three-dimensional projection of it looks
like that
as long as you don't close the cycle you
you have the possibility the avenue but
i mean if you go to 12
this hole closes
okay
okay
uh how about the non-degenerate exact
okay so so that's that's that's uh you
know let's now let's now
okay
let's stick to nasa to to to exact nas
equilibria so you know
approximation
is for
computer science nets
and and let's talk about that let's try
to say
what happens if it's non-degenerate okay
if it's not degenerate
uh then there is a way to do it okay and
i think i want to draw it for you
yeah of course
so
imagine that this is this is the
one that this is the the two by the the
uh
two simplex product okay
and uh so and you want to create a
dynamic okay so here's what you do
you pick a nice equilibrium
the point that it's it's a
non-degenerate game so it has and not
number of assumptions isolated
okay so you take one of them and from a
point here i'm going to define for you
the direction and speed of it of the of
the point okay
the direction is goes there
the speed is
proportional
to the
utility deficit versus the best response
the nasca
okay
and and and if you think about it
what we were doing will go there
everything happens to go by to pass by
an exact nurse equilibrium
it will stay there
so all them as a millionaire will become
the fixed points
so you only need to complete one
equilibrium yes exactly exactly
but is this easier or harder than
computing
right so right so so you know
because there's got it you know the
problem is that you have to
and the conjecture is
fine being able to go correct on merging
dynamics in non-degenerate games is
impossible unless people speak up
in polynomial time
okay
is this me
so in other words i conjecture that this
trick is only essentially the only thing
okay and there is another conjecture
about which we have fought a little less
but which i find very compelling finding
a utility increase in converting
dynamics in polynomial time is
impossible in this paper
okay
i don't know how many hardcore
sort of
complex theories are this audience but
but if you but uh
we have nobody has proved the theorem
like this
okay that creating a mathematical object
that has some properties
some properties that are very global
solving a dynamical system that that
that
okay that
is is intractable okay so so it will be
i in my opinion it would require some
new
some new methods
do we have a concrete idea
how the input should be the
algorithm should be the input and the
output i want to
[Music]
you know
i could i could i could sit down for 10
minutes and write a much longer much
longer conjecture that will answer these
questions but it would take the fun out
of yeah yeah so you know so you know
part of the fun is to sit down define
your your your model that will prove the
theorem okay then prove it okay yeah
i mean i don't think your paper will be
rejected because sort of you know you
you you you
did the wrong thing okay yeah
so
if you
i'm trying to think about
so if such dynamics
were possible they would be hard to
simulate
if ever no no you know but dynamics by
dynamics i mean
you you need you need euler's algorithm
right i mean
uh sort of you know
sorry
dynamics you don't know how to do
okay
yeah i i should i should have mentioned
this
okay
they must be here in the conjunction
only holds for the kinds of dynamics
treated here okay in other words uh
dynamics so in the sense of
dynamical systems and and continuous or
discrete time okay
and you know for example what about
stochastic dynamics and and we know that
that uh that muscular and heart
have uh have uh
something here okay in society dynamics
if you think about it
uh of course the converter can convert
to to approach the nash equilibrium
right i mean
the following comparison
pick a point at random
if you do it enough times
this will convert someone's equilibrium
to an approximate equilibrium
because then the bars approximate
equilibrium have a report
okay
and eventually
it will come close once and it will come
close infinitely often too no it will it
will
no no the issues no
and stop them
okay so you pick points at random and
you check whether it is it is a natural
equilibrium and approximate that's right
yeah yeah and this will converge
in exponential time i mean almost
yeah
as continuous
[Music]
like i mean
yes
i mean what what what muscular and heart
do is much more sophisticated the much
more constrained because because they
they require that you have limit very
limited
very limited information okay but i'm
saying from
from my standpoint so you know that's
not any that's not an interesting
problem
okay they're interested in general sort
of full information
i guess i wanted to contrast it with the
right so like your theorem
from earlier
yeah
it would impose a lot more constraints
yes exactly exactly exactly yeah yeah
yeah yeah
okay so i'm done i'm done with the
security results
and and and uh
and i'm going to the what now
what now
so
it
the problem is
that
you cannot design the dynamics that does
that i see yeah okay so you know so i
mean
we are trying you know we also let's
continue
we know the thing you know here is one
thing you can do okay you can you can go
whatever you are
you find your support and you check in
polynomial time if it has a massive risk
and you you go there okay otherwise you
go to a neighboring uh support right
okay you can't you know these are okay
so
so i'm coming to the important
battlefield okay okay you know so
basically uh it seems compatible not
only will computational dynamical system
okay and and
and
and
this has to be bad news for dynamics
right
or it is bad news for the last
equilibrium right so you know what is it
or it is the the the struggle that
breaks comes back okay uh
should we replace the natural caribbean
with the initial solution concept basic
dynamics
so
the
the prediction that economy and
economies should do from the game is the
fate of the dynamic
okay just follow the dynamics
uh i mean no that's what the solution
concept is a prediction well
what's your dynamics i'll tell you what
will happen
uh
so for example uh with georges who wrote
a paper with the the people that
demand
who
uh
basically to optimize their players they
follow the dynamics okay so no they
don't they don't they you know they
don't look for an equilibrium
uh
so the question is which dynamics okay
it does not matter much but let us fix
as a running example the replicator
dynamics no no regret learning okay the
continuous part of not regular 11.
and
what's going on
so where do dynamics end up
uh and there is uh there you know so
that's that's the question okay let's
fix the dynamics and we can argue after
that what it's going to be uh
peyton young in 1993 wrote a beautiful
paper the evolution of conventions
for and it was and it gave a dynamics
that works for something called weekly
uh
icicle games what is a weekly secret
game
a weekly secret game is the following
okay so
i'll try this on you and if you don't
understand what i'm saying please
interrupt me ask questions
consider
the
uh the sort of the game okay uh consider
the game the essentially the
uh
uh the the the
how should i say uh
the
uh
the graph
whose nodes
are the uh
uh
the pure pure uh pure strategy
the pure strategy profiles okay combined
for for both
and uh
they are they are sort of connected by
directed edge if uh that one is is the
best response okay
okay that's a that's a graph that's all
and well i like and understand right i
mean it's it's a it's a very it's an
exponential graph for large games and so
on so you know but but it's it's a it's
a way it's a well understood graph i
don't think main papers have read about
it so you know but but we all we all
know and love it
so basically
weekly and secret games
are these games
for which
the sync connected component of these
graphs
are single nodes are pure nash
equilibrium
does that make sense
okay ask ask me a question i'll i i can
explain but i mean that's what this
weekly secret games are so note the
nodes are strategy profiles the nodes
are strategic profiles and an edge is if
best response is the best response for
all the players
so each player has a different edge
so i mean
don't consider
who has red so no it's it's range of the
graph
okay
and basically it says who can go to whom
by by sequence of
best responses
okay
and and
the point is that this is the letter
graph
it may or may not be
uh strongly connected if it's not
connected it has strong right components
some of them are seen in other words no
it comes out of them
[Music]
exactly there are single tones they are
they are the nice equilibrium the
pureness equilibrium of the game
if they are not single dots
then
it's not a good classical game and peter
young's
theory does not apply what i'm going to
propose
if they're not synchronous they are
regular
you see what i'm saying
okay so and i mean we have to have a
theorem to support
uh okay
uh so for example uh
this is this is uh this is matching
penis it has only one command called
one codex component this is the
coordination game
it has it has uh
it has
one two
three four five no no
how many does it have it has five
five five uh
no it has has two
single equilibria right
yeah yes
um
so where do the dynamics
end up
maybe to pure equilibrium cycle so i
mean you see what i'm saying that uh
that these two examples tell us that
either they cycle
or they end up or they end up in in in
pure equilibria so i mean
maybe the
pure equilibrium cycles is that but
that's not right because things can be
very complicated okay even for two
player games
uh
so
how do you generalize peyton young's
approach to general games all right
and uh
it will take
a little a little so uh
here is here is what people have been
thinking about you know the the tuankare
is the genius who did a lot of things
including found dynamical systems and
he was able to uh to
pick
the
most beautiful low-hanging fruit okay
from this theory which is the
bendixone theorem okay
sort of stated it
and uh
and said that i know how to prove it and
everybody believed him and bending soon
did the work okay so you know
ten years later okay so so the
quantitative adiabatics and theorems is
the following uh that that in two
dimensions in two-dimensional dynamical
systems are very well behaved
they either cycle
or they go to a fixed point
okay
or there is another behavior which is
which is mixed and sort of you know and
yeah slightly more complicated doesn't
matter okay but that morally they either
go to fixed point or recycle
and uh
for the rest of the 20th century
essentially uh
people said but but in three dimensions
that does not hold okay
and then they discover those chaos in
three dimensions
right so and then then the sort of you
know they had what i call plunk arabics
on ebay okay what can we what can we do
in three dimensions that will bring us
back to the beautiful uh uh
situation we had in two dimensions okay
and finally uh uh conley in the 1980s uh
uh
proved what is called the fundamental
fear of dynamical systems and although
i'm going to explain it to you so you
know it's it's a it's a beautiful
beautiful theorem
uh
what is a chain recurrence set point
okay as a point is recurrent if if you
let it go it's going to cycle okay what
is chain recurrent
if it will cycle approximately in
particular it will go for a while then
it will make a little jump then it will
continue for a while it will go make a
little jump and it will end up where it
is
okay this means they are
that
that
for any
epsilon there is an n
so that
you define recur you know you you know
you define sorry you define that the
points change the current if
for every episode there is an end so
that this can happen
okay
so
basically uh
as uh
uh pongariz benigson theorem essentially
says uh
that that that uh
here here
okay um
so sponge theorem says that any
dynamical system ends up in some
recurrent set
drawn there by the puno function where
the point is also considered the fixed
point was also a considerable current
set okay
well
uh
conlay generalized it
80 years later to chain recurrent sets
okay
and many dimensions
okay
so
so
i have uh i have mixed my slides and i
apologize ah
okay so this is this is the the
explanation of the poncaribetixon
theorem but but i think i think i think
i i i i did explain it
without the slide
okay
so
any dynamical system ends up in some
chain the current set drawn there by
diamond function okay that's
in other words the ideal behavior
prevails in in more than two dimensions
as long as
you screen your eyes a little bit okay
so you know you you consider cycles some
some people some things that are not
cycles no there is there is a beautiful
adversarial interpretation of this okay
it says sort of you know that alice can
convince bob that
that that bob is recurrent
by only manipulating
bob's
floating point
accuracy
okay
so
this has
five uh
chain recurrent sets uh two are stable
and three are unstable this has one
chain recurrent set
uh
and they
change the current set of the game com
comprise a directed a secret graph okay
a hierarchy
and
this is the matching pen is dug and this
is the coordination games deck okay and
these are the things
all right
so intuitively
the fate of the game
are the sync crs
of the dynamics
and the whole that can be messy possibly
infinite but the ccrs are nice
okay
before going on you have to fix two
problems conversions can be very slow
and the solution is you are you
introduce arbitrary small noise and then
pureness equilibria extraneous pure mass
equilibria will will
will
uh emerge so you you moderate a little
this this arbitrary small noise okay so
you know this is this these are these
are technical details that uh uh so this
is this slide that's supposed to
introduce you to what is the graph that
i i talked to before uh
and it's this guy and
the structure of director graphs they
have things
and and
and the
they say the basic dynamics
so what is the learning dynamics that
i'm proposing
basic dynamics let's say replicator plus
arbitrarily
small gaussian noise
but we wanted to be support preserving
in the following sense
that
it is it is a noise such that it does
not acquire new dimensions
okay if you are you know the the
intuitive
the inspiration for this is evolution
okay so even you know so you know if the
trait is extinct it's exciting
and and
uh exception to support preservation at
pure strategy profiles noise means that
a random strategy is reintroduced at a
tiny level so that you don't get
you don't get extraneous uh pureness
equilibrium
so this is the dynamics and our theorem
is the following
in any game the learning dynamics that i
described almost certainly ends up in a
stressing strongly connected component
of the q strategy dynamics graph of the
of the of the of the best response graph
okay if you think a pure uh
a pure uh strategy a pure sorry a a sing
a sing connect strongly component
is essentially a generalization of
pureness equilibrium okay
just the mixedness equilibrium okay so
so i'm telling you let's let's not go
with the mixed nuts equilibrium let's
generalize the
unequivocally reasonable concept of
pureness equilibrium to somebody in a
different direction and then you get
sort of a different solution concept so
that's
uh how am i doing time
okay okay so so uh
okay so
all right so so this is this this
retells the story that i told you and i
want to tell you um
so follow the dynamics take two okay
that's that that's that's a very short
that's a very short uh uh discussion uh
what is a game for you
is it a specification venus equilibrium
selection problem because that's what
they have been telling us or an
algorithm that maps the distribution of
a mixed strategy profile the prior of
the gauges behavior
to a distribution over a set of markov
chains the various possible outcomes of
the dynamics
okay so
for example uh
distribution
supposed to have a distribution over the
domain okay
and like this okay so what is that what
is uh
what is the the probability you know
so that's the prior what's the
probability here is the measure of the
region of attraction okay
whatever is the measure of this that's
that's that's the probability of this
and the rest is the probability of of uh
i guess this
so the measure
component is uniform or is it some other
great question
we have written about this so you know
but but it's it's so no it's a name for
the game
i mean you have to find you know so
knowing
we have proposed
so
if c is a coordination game
then c the game the coordination game
is is a function that maps distributions
to distribution
and if the if the argument is uniform
the the uh the distribution the the
distribution is basically uh
fifty percent uh one coordination fifty
percent other coordination
matching penis is is
[Music]
from any institution
you end up doing this
okay
so these are two examples of what
i think the semantics of the game should
be
two very simple examples yeah so i i
want to be sure that i follow the
concept we are bored a little bit by
nasa equilibria and now we want to
understand something better so we say
that the game is not
the disappointment
yeah disappointing
so we want to say the game should stop
to be like the matrix the game should be
like also the behavior that we have
decided inside
and let's find out what are the
limit points of
that story and call them yeah
so sorry this notation doesn't happen
today now make sure that this
reviews the dynamics
uh so
so i mean
we have we have we have been working
with an example of this dynamic of the
replication of data
but
any reasonable for any reasonable
dynamics where is that remains so you
know
not going against uh again exactly
against utility
uh
would would support the theorem before
another of the government
okay so there is there is there are some
very mild uh assumptions
okay
yeah because
[Music]
nice
the connected components will also be
different or not i don't think so
i don't know
it will be the same right i mean
i mean you have you can
say
you can definitely your european
dynamics under my assumptions you can
show that like the second like limit
sets would be there
as uh as the users of this
process
but uh but there are some constraints
requires some assumptions that say
beyond continues so you want something
that's like minifee
the components
are
follow from uh from the from the
best response
graph so this is the non-dependent
dynamics
okay the components now whether all
components will be reached or you can
avoid some by manipulating the dynamics
you know so you know we have okay
initially the state variable was
is always the mixed strategy profile is
that half the state variable of this
string
because no regret dynamics you sort of
take averages oftentimes you look at the
average action of the players of the
time
uh
yes
so you kind of need t as part of the
statement so but we know we don't we
don't do that
i mean
for the average
the moon can sit there okay yeah so you
know
yeah what does this picture look like if
you switch from replicator for example
to smooth best response dynamics and
that takes in matching pens that
converges to the
mixed equilibrium
okay yes i mean also yes i mean i guess
i guess you knew that i don't know that
you can okay so
uh here we need the property
it's not allowed to grow
the conclusions would depend on the
dynamics and it's really fair
yeah i mean
you're right you're right i mean so
we should have been a little more
diligent to
[Music]
give the true class of dynamics for
which this holds potentially no but but
we have not done it
no frankly we have not written this
paper yet
[Laughter]
i guess it does not convert it does
[Laughter]
yeah so like uh
they're the dependencies
so let's just say choose your favorite
dynamics
and then see what the results
for our base additional
right i guess what i'm trying to
understand is the sync connected
components of the pure pure strategic
response yes
uh so there's a claim that the moderator
dynamics
[Music]
but i want to
remind you that i have
stopped talking about this i'm talking
about something new okay which is which
is that that you can very i believe very
productively
look at the game as a mapping
for prior distributions to perceive
posterior distributions so and in some
sense this is fundamentally
useful
okay so you know
no i believe it is mean
i'm not saying it's the right way to
look at games
but it is one way to look at games that
has not been explored
okay
and my point is that
for example i mean i gave you two to two
point two two uh two easy examples here
because that was again
so this defines the nature of a proper
american
developer efficient algorithms which
given again
in a high level description of
some kind of the priors
say uniform
find a high level description of the
resulting asymptotic distribution
this to me is worth thinking about
that's what i'm saying
uh
and to finish where we started to put it
differently
joe nash based his solution concept
on the most sophisticated
theorem topology of his time
and would be foolish not to do the same
so i have a non-technical question i
guess um
how are you thinking about like the four
cycle and matching pennies as a solution
concept like
like how should i think of that as a
prediction
of behavior
if i'm given that game so uh so i mean
the example i showed
i used those two as examples
and i was saying that
they are explicitly
some of the transformers one
distribution
on the on the on the on the
strategy profile space
to another
the prior to the posterior
and this is what the game should be i
don't know
for having fixed the data
right then i guess i'm saying
like are you saying if
if we watch people playing this game
then we expect them to cycle in this way
this one like what is the prediction of
like
so
so i mean
uh
so
i'm afraid that i i bought the talk in
the following sense that that i didn't
explain clearly that
i talked so far about about this stuff
about about the sync on the component
components
but now i'm going to tell you something
new
and the new stuff is
that the game fundamentally
is a mapping from a posterior
distribution of strategies through the
strategic space
from a prior distribution to possible
distribution
okay i'm sorry i'm changing completely
i'm forgetting now
remark of the mark of stuff
make sense
so to yeah up on that point so even in
the evolution of conventions
there's a prior distribution of the
sphere of distribution
in that case it was hardly one
equilibrium
but then there were follow-up papers
that said if you change the dynamics and
change the distribution
it
kind of opens up anything still that
that's any pure
equilibrium for example if they if there
are multiple can be made to be the
stable the dominant right
so it's
yes it's an approach and then personally
i think it's the right approach uh to uh
to back away from nash equilibrium but
still it's wide open and unless the the
dynamics and this there's some kind of a
dream though
right now yes
yep
[Music]
combined
so a a very open-ended question because
you said that okay i'm paraphrasing that
you in your open problem you're saying
that basically
uh we need to get some level
understanding of what
the
fate of the dynamics is going to be
if it's okay to paraphrase it
uh so uh i would just like to
uh zoom in a little bit on this and
understand what you what you got if you
can conjecture
what structural descriptions we can
accept or what kind of structural
theorems you think we could obtain in
characterizing this long-term behavior
so
of course not just equilibrium not
natural equilibrium fine
but
do you do you have a conjecture of what
this could look like or what not i mean
i don't know about theorems and and
theories uh but i mean like i guess what
what what georges and i have been
discussing
is some kind of black box
that sort of you know you you give it
some
some nice description of the input which
is the prior
let's say uniform okay so you know
a couple of different things also
and
there is a there is a there is a
black box that tells you okay you know
the probability here the distribution
here is like this
so we would like somehow not to simulate
the dynamics to to comp
without without without simulated
dynamics to understand statistically
statistically basically
what is the final behavior
is that this is always possible or that
is also complex i mean
it's going to be impossible okay right
so if i can also like jump in this
discussion which i feel is kind of like
open but at the same time central to our
to our maybe workshop
so yeah so so some initial uh
like questions here with uh crystals and
and
focusing on things like replicator is
because they led to objects that have
some sort of discrete nature like this
discrete like
directed class
and these actually are combinatorial
objects that have easy description and
it's something that we can meaningfully
work with right
but also how you remove or like you look
at more general dynamics then
the objects the limit objects somehow
that you have to work with are becoming
also
have their own increasing complexity
and then then there's a lot of back and
forth in terms of like okay what does
approximation mean in this case right
if this behavior is complex maybe yeah
like the way
you know we cannot compute an exact
equilibrium
exact mass but we are okay with
computing an approximate
and i'm going to say like okay maybe i
cannot confuse an exact limit behavior
what does it mean to come to an
approximate unique behavior
and i think this was this notion of like
this notion of approximation i think is
new
because we have to
combine this with apology which ideas
let's see if
approximation theory things are like
more discrete right
and i think it's relatively open-ended
and now you know if i
i hear that there are
new
new techniques in computational
apologies so i know that that seemed
promising
right right so
yeah i mean uh dynamicists have been
working around things like uh markov
county
um type of approximations
right so and these are some of the tools
somehow that we
into
we
juice in this area
but i think the question is like much
more open-ended
right and then i think the the
if you give the correct framing right so
don't
don't think that's
right now we think of the computational
problem of
games level as okay the input
is a gain matrix
the output is some approach and that's
equilibrium okay now it seems like
you're listening of a different game
the input something like prior over
initial conditions
the output is some posterior
distribution over
possibly correlated play
and how do you how do you approximate
this black box
computation but the input should also be
the learning dynamics yeah sorry the
input is also the learning dynamics so
that's it yeah that's the you're right
or or at that
black box so black looks parametric so
it's you know it's the heavy game and
the dynamic
and possibly some kind of a random
process
okay
any
any last questions
well thank christos again